should I do now? I'm not going to lie, so I have no choice. For the time being, I have no choice but to
take advantage of Abel's absence. I see, but it's
rare for a saint to be worried about being seen so much.
That doesn't happen to me.
Now,
Lauren
's eyes are filled with eyes because she
accepts it. It's not that she's
wary of other people, but
you're special. You've
been living with her for a while, after all.
Yes, but I feel a little relieved.
Even though she's my friend, I'm a little relieved. If I could be like that to someone I'm meeting for the first time, there would be
fewer Saints that only I know, and I'd be
sad. I'm sorry,
Saint, but I have to get ready soon.
[Music]
Lauren  is so honest that it's scary in a way